so where are we right now well just
under an hour ago Clark County election
officials updated their numbers after
more mail-in ballots were counted here
is where we stand in the big races right
now all right so let's start right now
with the race for the Senate incumbent
Catherine Cortez masto against
Republican Challenger Adam laxalt as you
can see currently just three percentage
points between the two candidates
turning now to the gubernatorial race
the race for governor incumbent Steve
sisilak trailing by nearly five
percentage points 46 to 50 plus for Joe
Lombardo Sheriff Lombardo leading by 35
000 plus votes and there are also those
three key house races up for grabs in
Clark County district one here the
incumbent Dina Titus managing to keep a
lead right now against the Challenger
Mark Robertson let's go to District
three Democrat incumbent Susie Lee
facing Challenger April Becker as you
can see on your television this race is
neck and neck separated by
3378 votes with Lee with that narrow
lead and right now District Four this is
also an incumbent to Democrat Stephen
horseford against Republican Sam Peters
with about four percentage points
between those two men the race for North
Las Vegas mayor occur in North Las Vegas
city council member Pamela goins-brown
ahead of current state senator Pat
Spearman with more than 30 points ahead
leading by nearly 17
000 votes 66 to 34 percent of very big
Landslide Victory there